to make sense of Northern Ireland then
and now speak to Paul Donnelly we're not
doing to each other what it was we did
in the past but there are still traumas
and Legacies we are still displaying
conflict behaviors considerably after
the events the Belfast tour guide takes
visitors through 25 years worth of
bombings and shootings and he knows the
central pillar of Northern Ireland's
peace The Good Friday agreement he
worked on it as a mediator it meant that
the various parties had been so
conflicted agreed that they were not
going to conduct the conflict in that
manner anymore so essentially it brought
an ounce to most of the violence signed
in 1998 The Good Friday or Belfast
agreement set up power sharing between
nationalists and unionists and brought
down barriers between Northern Ireland
and the Irish Republic but brexit is
stressed testing the agreement to
potential destruction questions about
the durability of the Good Friday
agreement and now coming from across the
political Spectrum whether that be Irish
Prime Minister Martin Northern Ireland's
unionists or those For Whom the
agreement over emphasizes divisions and
marginalizes the growing Center ground
a mock Funeral For the Good Friday
agreement did already say some unionists
because of the Northern Ireland protocol
part of the UK's post-brexit trading
arrangement with the EU the protocol
established an effective Customs border
between Northern Ireland and the British
Mainland unionists and unacceptable
revision of Northern Ireland's place in
the UK Northern Ireland's constitutional
possession was supposedly protected by
the agreement but what we have seen
through the Northern Ireland protocol
was that guarantee that promise was a
sham it wasn't worth the paper that was
written on so what about this agreement
is worth saving this interest Alliance
party has different concerns it wants
the agreement rebalanced so unionist all
nationalist parties aren't able to
obstruct functioning government I think
that to have a good Friday agreement
that's fit for purpose in 2022 we need
to remove the beetles that are currently
being abused by Shin Fein and the dep
there's currently a Third Way in
Northern Ireland it's not just unionist
versus National
Northern Ireland currently has no
functioning government unionists have
collapsed power sharing over the
Northern Ireland protocol the UK
government is obliged to call new
elections but few see this as a fix even
after that election we don't know how
it'll be possible to get the executive
functioning again given that the dup is
still likely to veto participation The
Good Friday agreement was foundational
for Northern Ireland's peace and if you
want to know what's at stake here Paul
Donnelly will take you through it every
bullet and bomb Rory challenge Al
Jazeera Belfast